hi there so if you look at these two
robots the left one labeled blocking the
right one labeled concurrent the
blocking robot as you can see always has
these little pauses in its movement
where it does nothing and then it kind
of continues with its motion while the
one on the right is one continuous
motion that it does so the reasoning
here is that the robot has a camera and
the camera takes some time to register
what's going on and then also the robot
has a computer inside and the computer
also takes some time to decide what to
do based on what the camera saw and
while all of this is happening the robot
on the left just freezes so it performs
an action and then it freezes because it
takes time to register a state and
compute a new action whereas the robot
on the right it takes the same amount of
time to do these things right it also
takes a time to register the state and
the computed action but it does that as
it is executing the last action so it
does this in parallel and then it
executes the action once it's computed a
new action it executes that new action
right on top of the old action and that
gives this one big fluid motion so this
requires a new formulation of
reinforcement learning and that's what
this paper does thinking while moving
deep reinforcement learning with
concurrent control by people from Google
brain UC Berkeley and X so I they have a
nice diagram here in the supplementary
material to show you what is going on in
their framework so in classic
reinforcement learning right here in
classic reinforcement learning you have
this dichotomy between agent and
environment right so the agent and the
environment now the agent is supposed to
kind of act in the environment in the
following manner the environment will
send an observation to the agent the
observation in this case is the picture
of the of the camera so it sends an
observation and the agent will say
what to do with the observation which is
called a policy the policy PI will take
an observation and and then output an
action of what to do and will send back
the action to that environment right so
in classic RL you assume that this part
here is kind of freezes time so the
environment will output an observation
and as and the process of registering
the observation of computing the action
and of sending the action back is
happens in zero time of course it
doesn't happen in zero time but in our
reinforcement learning problems for
example the open a I Jim the environment
just stops until it gets the next action
and then it performs the action right it
performs the action in environment and
by that the environment changes and time
happens and then it stops again as we
think of the next action right so this
is we usually call this one step in the
in the kind of classic formulation of RL
the only point that time happens is when
the action is executed no time happens
when the state is registered or when the
action is computed and that's what you
see here on the left so in blue you have
the state registration this is for
example the camera the camera has some
time in order to register and store the
image that it has taken right maybe post
process it a little bit so that's what
the camera does but in our classic
formulation as you can see here if this
is time it happens instantaneously all
at the same time and also this is the
policy this is thinking what to do right
this is your evaluation of your neural
network if this is a neural network
drawing a small neural network here this
happens instantaneously in these
formulations and
only as the action is executed time
happens right and then until here time
freezes again and only once the action
is determined time happens again in the
new formulation now as you've already
seen what what we have here is this this
kind of continuous framework where let's
say you're here
it actually takes time for the camera to
post process the image it takes more
time for you to think about what to do
and then once you decide on an action
that action is going to happen right but
we can we can say for example at this
point you tell the camera to take a new
picture of the state right but that
takes time and while that's happening
the old action is still ongoing
right so you don't even even have to say
the action is still ongoing but the
world is still moving right the world is
still changing while you think while you
post process and while you evaluate your
policy the world is thinking and only
after some time right after this lag
time here have you decided on a new
action and then you can break that old
action and kind of perform your new
action and all of this is happening in
time so this this is the new framework
now you see the problem here the problem
is that you base your decisions on the
state and time T on time sorry time age
here you base your decisions on the
state as it was at that time right
that's what you use to think right here
that's what you store and think about
but you perform so you perform the
action at this point in time so there is
a considerable difference here because
the world has now changed so you see the
problem the action you perform is based
on an old knowledge of the world and you
have basically no way of making the
action dependent on the current state of
the world because that would require you
to
capture the current state and that takes
time and in that time the world has
already shifted again so the agent is
kind of required to think ahead about
the action that it is currently
performing and how the world changes
according to that so this new
formulation of reinforcement learning
formulates this in an in a formal way it
formulates it in a formal way and we'll
quickly go through that yes so they go
into the very basics here we'll quickly
quickly go through them so they
introduce these quantities like the
policy PI the transition distribution
the reward and the queue and value
function now we'll just quickly go over
these so you have the agent sorry about
that
you have the agent and you have the
environment hello so if you think of the
agent and the environment the
environment has this transition function
transition function the transition
function it takes it says okay I'm in
this state and the agent does this
action and here's the probability
distribution over the next state right
so it says that your little spaceship is
here right and the meteors are here and
then you push the button if if you push
the button for shoot then you will be in
the same place the meteors will still be
here but you'll have a little shot
coming out of your spaceship that's what
the environment does right so you give
it a state and action and it will give
you the next state it will also give you
a reward right the reward
in the same thing the reward here will
be a second output here that tells you
either let's say negative one if you're
you die or zero if nothing happens or +1
if you shoot a meteor that's the reward
so this you can think of as the real
world so these two quantities are in the
real world in the environment so that's
how you model the environment then the
agent has these quantities called the
policy pi so pi what pi does is much
like the transition but pi takes in a
state and gives you an action right so
this is now the agent deciding this is
thinking the policy takes in a state and
gives an action and this this can takes
various forms but it's just a function
for now the agent also has a Q and a v
function and these are quite quite
similar so the Q function what the Q
function will do if if you are in a
state and you have several options of
what to do right you have action one
action to and action three right in your
in state s the Q function of s and a 1
superscript PI would tell you the
following it would tell you what's my
expected reward if I'm in state s that's
here and perform action a so a 1 so if I
now take this path and after this path I
follow the policy pi write the policy PI
for each of the following so it's like
right now I take action a 1 I don't care
about my policy but after that I follow
the policy PI what is my expected reward
going to be until the end of the episode
that's the Q function and the value
function here very similar but it only
cares about the state it says if I'm in
state s and I just follow the policy PI
even in
the first step right I just follow this
policy pi what is my expected reward
going to be over the course of the
episode that is the Q and the value
functions you can see why Q learning is
popular if you have a good Q function
and the Q and the value function these
are the things that you actually want to
learn right if you have a good Q
function you can simply always plug in
every action into your Q function and
then simply take the maximum the action
that has the maximum Q value because
that will can that will give you the
best reward if if your policy PI right
it's kind of self referential if your
policy to is to always take the maximum
Q value then taking the maximum Q value
with the policy given that you take the
maximum Q value will be optimal all
right this was very convoluted but
alright so let's let's start off with
modeling the environment in this
continuous framework so instead of
having the next state be determined by
the current state in action in the
continuous framework they do this via
differential equation so the DS is how
does the environment change this is the
change in the environment that is
determined by two functions F and G so f
is your classic environment function it
takes in a state and an action at time T
right these are not functions and it
will it will output how the state
changes and the G here is this is a
wiener process is to introduce
stochasticity as I understand it because
in the classic formulation the
transition model gives you a probability
up here a probability distribution so
this Wiener process is responsible for
introducing that probabilistic nature
into this differential equation but
ultimately it simply tells you how does
the state change depending on my state
current state and action that I
perform so the reward function now is
also pretty simple the Tao here is a
trajectory and the trajectory is simply
the state and action over time so if I
integrate from time zero to infinity or
to the end of the episode my reward
function at each point in time right so
I go through my episode and I get higher
reward not so high and so on so the
integral under this curve will be my
total reward
just like we sum up the reward of
individual steps in the discrete case in
the continuous case you can think of
each infinitesimal time step giving you
a tiny bit of reward so the entire
reward is just an integral then we go on
the value function for a given state at
time T right so think about what this is
the value function for a state means
what reward can I expect starting in
this particular state and then following
policy PI until the end of the episode
and that here is the expectation over
all trajectories that come from my
policy of the reward in that trajectory
so I can you know if I'm here my policy
now is also a distribution it can go
multiple trajectories right and I want
to I want to have the expected value of
the reward so each one of these has a
reward the expected value of the reward
over all trajectories starting from
state s T and again here you say that
that is the integral over T now here I
have a bit of a problem because here
they say T equals zero going from here
and here but here the T is already here
so I leave this should be this should be
T equals
Prime and then T prime T prime T prime
up here and t minus T prime or something
like this in any case I think it should
it should actually start from this state
here and not from time zero but I might
be missing something I'm not the biggest
integrator in the world so you know
alright then you have the Q function now
think of it what the Q function is in
the discrete case the Q function tells
you if I'm in state s and perform action
a what is my expected reward going to be
that I have to introduce some different
things here they say if I'm in state s
and I act action a at time T until time
H right now you have to say how long
you're gonna perform the action for
until you perform the next action right
so H is your Ural act I'm here until you
perform the next action so this now I
actually agree with this formulation
with the integral here so this is going
to be the integral from time T to time T
plus h that's how it long you perform
the action your reward of performing
that action right given the state plus
the value function at the end of that so
you're ear here
you're an ST and you perform action a
right and then this is your state at
time T plus h and then you're here and
from there on you could perform many
many many actions right but in the
original notion of the Q function the Q
function tells you if I'm here and I
perform this action and after that I act
according to pot to a policy PI what is
my what is my expected reward and but
there's a classic recurrence relation in
reinforced
learning where you can say the Q
function in st given to a is the reward
that I get from performing a in state s
plus the value function at state s at
the stat the next state right because
the value function is exactly the reward
that you would get by following policy
PI in that next state and the Q function
means I perform a now and after that I
perform PI so this is the continuous
analog that's why you have this part
here where you perform the action for
each time and after each time you just
go after go with your policy and that
will be the value function so this is
the continuous formulation of the of the
problem right and now they can introduce
these these lagging times so in their
diagram up here they define these
notions so you have your state s T right
here then after this time you capture
the new state right so after that time
you capture the new state and decide on
an action and then you perform it for
each time is that correct until here so
the the the I minus one of action is
performed at this time and the I F
action is performed at this time no that
makes no sense so
let's read it ah so this is when you
capture the state and you need time to
perform to think right this is thinking
and then you perform this action at that
time this is the lag time now and you
perform this action you want to know you
want to know if I perform this action
until this time here
what is what is happening so this is the
new cue function takes into account this
thing it tells you if I'm in state s and
I think this is thinking leads me to
here this is the old action right this
is the old action that's still happening
well I observe this state right so it
means if I do this right now
and after thinking I do this right so
I'm at state I'm at time T and this is
still happening and then after I think
thinking leads me here T plus TAS I
perform this new action a lot of colors
I perform this new action at that point
until time H what's my cue function so
my cue function is going to be the
integral time T where I start observing
the state and start thinking until T
plus TAS that's when I still perform the
old action right so this is going to
read the reward in the state given the
old action and then at that time I
switch over to the new action
right so at that time until time age now
I perform the new action so this entire
part here this part until here is taking
the place of this first part here in the
cue function of this first part right so
because before it was simply executing
one action we didn't have this
concurrency yet so executing the action
and after that it's going to be the
value function and now it's executing
two actions first execute the old action
then once you're done thinking execute
the new action and then it's the value
function from their own I hope this is
clear it wasn't clear to me until just
now as well alright so they define the
Monte Carlo estimator where you can do
this with just samples of the of
trajectories instead of expectations and
then they define the bellmen operator
the bellmen backup operator now the
bellman back-up operator is an important
quantity in value-based reinforcement
learning because the bellman backup
operators basically what I talked about
before it's it tells you that if your
policy is them to always select the
maximum the action with the maximum Q
value right that's what's down here
after you do this action then the then
the policy you arrive at and you can
give certain optimality guarantees but
in essence this is clear called a
contraction so if you always do that and
you calculate your Q function that way
it will mean that in the contraction is
defined as if you have an operator if
you have two things that are X 1 and X 2
that are some apart from each other then
after you apply the operator this T here
X 1 minus
tx.2 they will be closer together which
basically means that the q TQ functions
of the individual states will be closer
together and you'll converge to a single
Q function right so given enough time
and enough data you'll converge on one q
function there's one fixed point q
function that you'll converge to and you
can show under assumption in classic RL
that this is going to be the the optimal
Q function the the true let's say Q
function so they first prove this and
then they prove it now they go back to
discrete time so now they were in
continuous time they go back to discrete
time but now they have a discrete time
formulation with this lag here and also
they prove that that
bellman operator is a contraction so the
contraction part basically means that if
you perform Q learning you're going to
arrive at a solution that's what it
means to be contraction but now
obviously that solution in classic RL is
going to be the the optimal Q function
but here I actually don't know all right
so they try this out and they introduce
one last important concept here what
they call a vector to go which basically
means that at the point where they start
thinking where is a good thing to show
this at the point where they start
thinking they give a they give the the
last action with so at this point right
here where they sorry where they capture
the state they also sort of the state
contains a information about what part
of the action that you started here is
still outstanding so maybe your
action was and they illustrate this down
here maybe your action was to move your
robot arm from down here to up here
right that was your plan to action at
this point in time now if you are at
step if you perform the action here and
here you start capturing the next state
then you would also give this particular
vector here to the to that to the agent
so not only will you tell it hey by the
way my last action was a t minus one as
you would need in the q-value you will
also say and this much is outstanding
this is much is whereas I I still have
to do that much so basically you're
saying I wanted to move my arm right
here and I still have to do this part of
the action now you can see while the
algorithm is able to learn much better
given that information because otherwise
it has it would have to basically infer
that vector from kind of differencing
the action - the what probably happened
in the meantime
right so they test this out and what
results is the robot videos you've seen
before where they say they can recover
the original the original q-learning
in this continuous framework so here on
the left side you have blocking actions
and it says when it says yes here it is
kind of the old old framework you see
the grasp success at like 92% where as
if you go to non-blocking actions but do
none of the none of the concurrent
information the grasp success suffers
but you can recover the grasp success if
you if you give these concurrent
information like even introduce a time
step penalty and you give this vector to
go and the information about the
previous action
you can also see that the episode
duration here is much lower when you go
for the continuous actions then when you
are in the old framework naturally
because you don't need to pause right in
this so this is the simulated robotics
and the real world robotic grasping
results you see kind of similar results
in that if you do have blocking actions
your grasp success is higher than if you
don't but your duration of your of your
policy is cut in half
so maybe this is a trade-off worth
considering I think this is a is pretty
cool framework and I think there's going
to be a lot of work still outstanding
here and I invite you to check out the
paper and look at their videos and their
ablation studies of what's important and
what not and with that bye bye